boundaries aren't for them they're for  you and if someone violates your  boundary you don't set another boundary  you remove yourself from the situation  that's a personal boundary you take  responsible for your energy and how  contagious it is you know energy  contagion is so real and when watching a  horse when it's around  ugly energy or energy that doesn't serve  them that's depleting or confusing just  removes itself that was a tool that I  didn't even know existed yeah like it  didn't even occur to me you could just  like leave if someone wasn't you didn't  have to keep talking you know just get  up and go you know I didn't even know  that was an option I thought it was like  you get on the dance floor and you're  dancing until your partner gets off like  just go sit on the bench when in doubt